hi everyone
my name is matt i'm one of the lead
maintainers of desk and today we're
going to talk about
the challenges and opportunities of
deploying das at scale
so this argument usually falls into the
three
easy identifiable sections first is a
library like dasks
makes parallel algorithms really easy to
run
uh it provides things like parallel
pandas parallel pi probably machine
learning libraries
parallel other stuff
but there ends up being a lot of
additional i.t challenges that get in
the way of being productive
these are things you wouldn't normally
anticipate they're things like well how
do i build docker messages with just my
right set of libraries
or how do i make things secure or how do
i
uh how do i invite team members and
manage their their usage
these things are annoying but they end
up actually stopping a lot of progress
and so we've actually focused a lot on
the last couple of years
uh and then third using this sort of
argument there's there's some sort of
sales pitch at the end and this talks
will be no different
uh i'm going to talk about coiled which
is where i work i'm going to try to you
know
show how we've solved these problems
actually going to skip the first section
i'm not going to talk that much about
desk
i've given i don't know how many talks
about das in the past i
and others have recorded talks that are
available on youtube or other sources
if you haven't heard about task i
recommend watching one of those first
i'm going to assume that you know what
task is and that you already want to use
it
uh maybe you've used it on a laptop
maybe you've seen some cool talks about
it
maybe you're trying to scale out and
you're curious about how to get started
this talk we're going to talk a lot more
about the it challenges but what it
takes to actually get up and running
on real hardware uh on the cloud or
elsewhere
and we're going to focus most of our
time there with a motivating example
at the end again i'm going to give you a
punchline a solution
that's going to be coiled and i'm going
to encourage you to run these three
lines of code
which will run a cluster for you so
that's where we're headed but i want to
first spend a lot of time
thinking about how we get to those three
lines and what they do under the hood
so let's dive in let's start with an
example
let's say that you are a data scientist
and that you want to use pandas and xg
boost
to train a model this is really
accessible today
due to a lot of great work in the
community you can do things like
conda install xgboost and pandas onto
your laptop
you might download some data set like
the higgs boson training data set from
amazon s3
you then start up you know ipython
jupyter a python script
you'll import your libraries load a csv
file
there's probably some feature
engineering here i'm skipping over then
you're going to train that model with xg
boost
and this is actually a really accessible
workflow this is why we love pi data
anyone in the world with access to a
laptop
and some time to learn can do this work
and that is a
an incredible testament to what we've
accomplished
now if you're trying to do that on
larger data sets things can get a little
bit more complicated
now maybe you've seen some documentation
you know the pandas docks the xgboot.exe
boost docs
and you're curious about how to how to
increase scale here
both of those will mention das dasc is a
popular library for pillow computing in
python
which integrates with lots of popular
python libraries today
okay so you add dash to your content
install commands
and you switch out pandas for dash data
frame and you use the extra boost dash
model
or the xboost task module rather than
the xg use module
this works just fine on your laptop or
on workstation
this is also really accessible it might
require a little bit more time to learn
and you know there's some extra
complications here but this is again
still a very accessible workflow
anyone in the world can do this there's
not a lot of complication here
where things get tricky as you start
going to multiple machines especially
machines that you
yourself do not own and control and so
you might extend this process and use a
library like
das kubernetes maybe you have a
kubernetes cluster at work
maybe you're just excited about
kubernetes so you're going to
import some project like the das
kubernetes library get the kubernetes
cluster object
and use that to connect to kubernetes
cluster
now wait a minute for a second this
this requires some more setup you need a
cluster you will authenticate it to it
uh we're now
going directly to s3 uh with our das
workers
uh so there's some more setup here that
needs to be done so let's go and dive in
and see what it is
we needed to do to set that up so
the first thing you might do is you'll
probably do a web search right maybe
ask on the cloud that will link you to
our documentation
on das cloud deployments it's a great
starting point
when you go there you'll see that there
are a few different options
you could use something like kubernetes
and there's a whole documentation page
on the different options of kubernetes
you might choose
you might also choose something like
yarn something like amazon emr is really
familiar to
people who've come from the spark world
that's also a great entry point
you might also use something like das
cloud provider this is actually my
preferred way as an individual to launch
desk on the cloud
other than coiled and you might try that
instead but
many people today try kubernetes so
let's let's go down that route let's say
you click on that link
okay what you'll find first is that you
need to set up a kubernetes cluster
probably you work somewhere or you're a
student and your workplace university
has access to a cloud account you're
probably going to ask your it
department for credentials and they'll
probably give them to you they'll
probably email you a csv file
with a secret and key but they're going
to do some work on the back end to make
sure that works
then you're going to log in to you know
amazon azure
google here i'm using aws just because
we see it come up the most often
but the workflow here is kind of the
same on any of the clouds
you'll probably look at the kubernetes
service attached to that cloud and
amazon it's eks
and you'll create a cluster you'll
specify some things like node pools and
how big a machines you want to use
but this is pretty straightforward you
can point and click on this if you're
not you know too
uh too turned off you probably also need
to install something like cube cuddle to
control your kubernetes cluster
this isn't strictly necessary but it's
it'll end up being helpful you're going
to want to clean some things up add some
things inspect what's going on
so you're probably going to curl this
down uh you know modified a little bit
and run it uh docks here pretty
extensive this is probably not something
that you're familiar with
but you can be and this is again good
training maybe you're enthusiastic and
you want to learn
so you've set up your kubernetes cluster
we're now ready to run our script again
there are some things you're going to
want to add into this kubernetes cluster
object which i'm kind of skipping over
but there's some setup some
configuration
you'll be okay the documentation again
is is pretty good
so you set that up you run your script
and
get a module not founder so this is the
first it problem we're going to run into
other than just setting up our
kubernetes cluster and what you find is
that you don't have extra boost
installed
that's confusing because you've already
installed xgboost it turns out that
errors like this are coming from your
das workers
even though you have actually boost
installed on your local machine or on
some notebook you're running in the
cloud
you actually don't have that installed
on all of the containers that you're
running on kubernetes
so that's not a problem you can go and
build a docker image
right so maybe you go look at the the
desk docker images
it's a good starting place we do lots of
nice things in there like clean up
access packages
sort of try to reduce the docker image
size it'll change around the packages
there you'll add maybe xg boost
and then you will if you make a docker
hub account you'll
build that docker image and push it up
if you don't have docker installed you
might install it
you know linux and mac you'll probably
be fine
so we start again we now have changed
our configuration in that kubernetes
cluster we're using
a separate docker image that we've
already created and pushed up to the
cloud
we're ready to start again so we run our
computation and
there's an s3 permission error this is
awkward we didn't get this
originally on our laptop that's because
we actually had credentials on our
laptop
but our das workers on our kubernetes
cluster don't have those same
credentials
those pods those containers don't look
like us they don't have the same
credentials that we have
and so if your data set the data set
that you are trying to read
isn't publicly accessible or if it
requires some sort of authentication in
order to download
you're gonna need to somehow figure out
how to distribute your credentials
onto your das workers on your kubernetes
cluster
the sort of hacky way to do this is to
use das itself
das provides mechanisms to upload files
to all of your workers
this will work but please please don't
do this there's lots of reasons why you
shouldn't do this and we're going to get
into those in a second
but let's say you've done that for now
just to get things up and running
you've propagated your aws credentials
to all of your workers
so that when they run aws commands they
they look like you
aws knows that it's you trying to do
this work
so we're ready to try our script again
and
it actually works this is amazing you
have trained an extra boost model at
scale
and this is this is super exciting at
this stage you are
you are thrilled you're seeing lots of
work happen on your cluster
you can scale it out you can scale it
down you scale up to you know 20
terabytes of
memory and you start uh you start doing
lots of different things
this ends up being actually a great time
for you
you have the tools now to scale anything
remember that desk integrates with with
tons of different libraries and so you
can do tons of different kinds of
workflows
and this just adds a new tool uh to your
toolbox
you can combine with all of your
pre-existing tools so it's again a very
exciting time
you can scale out and you can control
hundreds or
thousands of machines from anywhere
and that's that's really fun uh
so uh you can even try gpus for a little
bit uh this will end up being awkward
for other reasons you're
not going to buy knock and want to do
this i'm going to point you to a talk i
gave recently at
nvidia's gtc conference which talks
about some extra challenges for gpus
we're not going to go there for now but
this may be a small plug
so again things are good you're really
happy right now
until it finds out so you're going to
get an embarrassing email
from it and ask lots of questions uh
they'll say something like we've been
checking our pricing logs and you are
apparently spending
some many thousands of dollars per month
uh
the actual work that you're doing is
fine right the work that you're doing is
generating value it's worth the money
that the company is spending
the university spending on that compute
time
but the majority of your costs actually
aren't coming from your work
uh in your early experimentation maybe
you left up some idle clusters and
they've been
on running 24 7 for for some time
uh also some of the early experience
experiments that you ran
created extra resources that you didn't
really weren't really aware of
like networking issues or load balancers
and those have remained active
uh anybody who's played the cloud long
enough has been hit by this
uh you will too it's fine um
another issue uh it now they've been
aware of this topic
because of the cost issues they start
looking at your system
right and they're sort of curious about
the system task that you're running
which allows for the execution of
arbitrary python code on hundreds of
machines inside of their network
and this raises some security questions
uh one thing that comes up is that you
probably didn't implement something like
tls security you're probably not using
certificates
uh and so anyone if they knew the
address of your schedulers
could run as you uh inside your network
uh fortunately this hasn't happened but
it's something you should be aware of
and probably not do in the future
you're also sending sensitive company
data along unencrypted connections
you know to and from the kubernetes
cluster you know for example remember
those kubernetes
uh sorry remember those aws credentials
you might have sent those
over the open internet so anyone along
the chain from your laptop
to the cluster could have read them
again they probably didn't but it's the
kind of thing you probably don't want to
do
those abs credentials also allow for
impersonation
so it's likely that at this point you've
been successful enough that you've
showed this to your team and they're
also very excited uh you've probably
given them access
to that cluster but they might be
operating as you now
they need to manage their own
credentials on those kubernetes clusters
and this is this is again fine but it
would prefer that you didn't do that
so fortunately nothing bad happened but
you now need to be a little bit more
careful
uh and this is good timing because again
your teammates
all want to use this same system they
want the same power that you've had
over the last few months as you've built
up this capability
so this has got really good timing and
and you're also now in charge
you're the only person in your group
that understands both the data problems
you're trying to solve
and also enough of the sort of i.t cloud
devops problems
to control things uh this is either
great
or terrible uh if you want a career
change this is a great one
there's lots of money to be made here or
maybe you just wanted to be a scientist
and this maybe isn't great uh
uh as a side note putting on my sort of
for-profit hat for a second here
a lot of coils early customers have gone
through exactly
this trajectory their data scientists
who are really high performing
uh figure out the cloud just enough and
then as they get into it they realize
ooh
this is this is more than i wanted to
handle or even something that they're
excited about they're spending you know
a quarter
or a half of their time uh handling this
stuff and it's not really
certainly cost efficient right maybe
they're spending five thousand dollars a
month
on cloud costs but their salary is you
know ten thousand dollars a month
uh and so this just doesn't doesn't
quite make sense it's a lot of work
so let's go back in time and try a
different approach
um this is again we're gonna get a
little bit into the sort of sales pitch
here for a second
so we're we're not going to solve cube
cuddle we're not going to create a
kubernetes cluster we're not going to
we might still ask for a a role on the
cloud from our iit department
we're not going to go through different
options uh what we're going to do
instead we're going to try
coiled so again putting my sales hat
here for a moment
uh the das maintainers have seen this
happen
many many times this exact same path
some of us actually made a company to to
automate that process and that company
is
coiled we started in february of this
year and it's actually been a really
exciting growth to see people
jump on we try to make it easy to run
desk
on the cloud or on other infrastructure
uh the uh the punchline of this whole
talk
is to try uh running pip install coiled
and then import coil then create a coil
cluster and this will do
everything that we've talked about for
you in a safe secure way
let me actually just go and do that for
a second uh
so i'm going to open up by python
i'm going to import coiled let's see if
i can bump that up a bit
and i'm going to make a coil cluster
now what this is doing this is launching
a bunch of resources
on the cloud in a nicely authenticated
secure way handling
everything we just talked about it's
gonna take about a minute uh the cloud
we can get machines in about a minute
that's sort of a faster we're able to go
right now
i'm gonna jump back to slides and we're
gonna come back to this in just a second
so the main goal of coiled is to launch
das clusters for you it does lots of
other things but this is this is the
main objective
in the background we're using low-level
cloud apis
to provision cloud resources on the fly
we actually are not using kubernetes
because that would require
a different infrastructure it doesn't
allow us to be quite as global we're
going a little bit lower level
to give you a bit more access
to running you know anywhere on the
earth in any cloud
and also be very fast we spin up
resources in about a minute today
uh and this is fun and this again does
everything that you need
uh and it handles everything for you
uh let me jump back to our machine here
so we can see here a few things we can
see again i'm still
running um still creating things it
looks like i've asked for four workers
by default
i'd also see some historical workloads
here i can see that i've
recently i think just actually before
running this talk i was going through a
dry run
let me see what i was running before uh
that i
you know uh created a different cluster
it was costing about
two dollars an hour and a total of 40
cents
looks like our cluster has come up uh no
workers have arrived yet but that's okay
we can get started anyway
so i'm going to connect to that cluster
with
with desk and there's an interesting
warning here which we're going to get to
in just a second
uh let's go and look at the dashboard
for that cluster
let's pop that up
and so now if i want to i can you know
import you know any dash library
like maybe desk array and i can you know
start making some resources so here i'll
make a
looks like this is a 16 18 20 gigabyte
desk array
and i can compute some of that array and
so this is great
this is normal to ask things we can go
ahead and scale up
this will again take about a minute
that's about our response time on asking
for resources
um but you know i can import data frame
[Music]
and go through other das computations
anything i could do with dasc i can now
run
with desk on the cloud at scale in a
very comfortable way
so this is a lot of fun and we're going
to get back to this example a little bit
as we go through slides
i want to talk about what's happening
under the hood and what are the
different kinds of situations that we
run into
uh that we need to solve and we've seen
those before in our previous example
right we need to install libraries uh
we're going to figure out security
we need to figure out authentication and
all those things are happening for us
right now automatically
so the first of those is manage software
how do we
add the libraries that we care about
onto our dash workers
on the fly and how do we share those
around how do we version them there's a
lot of sort of social things that happen
with these software libraries many of
our users
don't actually understand docker that
well people
a lot of data scientists have some
docker familiarity but it's not a tool
that they use on a daily basis
so this is one of the things that we
handle for you you can register software
environments with coiled
you see a screenshot here on the left
and coiled will uh will
solve those for you it will build them
for you and it will also allow you to
con to install them
on other machines in the future so you
can sort of match that sort of remote
and local development experience
we're actually seeing that a little bit
here uh notice that uh das is actually
complaining a little bit
about different versions between my my
laptop experience
and my my deployed experience looks like
actually on my laptop
i've got a development version of desk
running that's okay but
that's making us aware of that and if i
want to keep that in sync
coil gives me the tools to do so let's
uh
it looks like again about a minute
through our computation
more workers workers arrived and we can
go ahead and do some computations
so uh again
the one additional the first additional
step software management
if you go in and look at at coiled we
can see that you actually have a lot of
software environments
that i that i manage right that i've
been using in my experiments and i can
use and deploy those
as i want in the future
so moving on uh das sorry
coiled lets you run in a very flexible
development environment
so i want you to notice that when i was
running that
example over here i'm actually the left
side of the screen
i'm just running ipython on my laptop
right i can run coiled from anywhere
coiled does host notebooks you can run
notebooks uncoiled
but we don't force you into that
experience a lot of our users actually
already have a notebook solution or they
want to work from their laptop
maybe they've got you know pycharm or vs
code set up just
the way they like it most of the time
that
the das users develop code they're
actually not using desk
task is used only sort of when you need
to scale
we want to try very very hard not to
force you into
our development environment instead
coyle tries very hard
to come to where you are and work within
your development environment
so this means that a coiled is publicly
accessible the clusters that you run
can be accessed from anywhere assuming
that you are authenticated effectively
and that really allows for a lot of a
lot of new applications
you can use coiled from aws sagemaker
you can use coiled again from your
laptop from any ide that you have
running
you can use coiled from automated
scripts running on prefect
um we really tried to decouple
uh the again the development environment
from the compute environment
and that's been actually really exciting
it opens up a lot of very fun
applications that weren't available
before
third cost management again
in that scenario where you become the
devops person
you end up having a team that all wants
to run the same
the same system and some of those team
members are going to be really on top of
things and some of them aren't they're
going to be new
and you're going to want you're going to
want to be able to
manage and shape and control their usage
and also track their usage over time and
so that's why coil provides things like
uh like cost metrics right i can see
that my cluster
has cost us 15 cents so far and i can
track this
not just with my workloads but on anyone
in my team
so you know in my particular team
there's only me
but if i go to maybe the coiled account
uh there are actually
you know a variety of team members that
i work with that are working on the
coiled team
uh and we can control you know things
like the the core limits maybe marcos
here
uh has been uh he's been pretty good
about costs we can increase his limit up
to 500.
and these sorts of quotas and cost
tracking and cost limiting
uh are actually really uh really
critical and organizational setting
coil does lots of other things to to
manage your
uh your costs again we track usage per
user and protein
we also do common sense things like
shutting down idle clusters
after you know 20 minutes by default uh
there's no more leaving clusters on over
time
we scan for idle resources in case
anything has been missed and we clean
them up
we provide toggling for things like gpus
we also again provide gpus we skipped
over this
uh when we're going through the x2 boost
pandas example
but gpus can be amazingly powerful
and amazingly cost effective in the
right situations uh you might be aware
of some of the
sort of desk friendly gpu libraries like
rapids or pytorch
or xgboost or blazing sql and you might
have seen some of their talks and you
want to try it out
uh handling kubernetes on the cloud is
doable if you have some
some gumption gpus end up being a whole
other
whole other level of complexity we work
very closely with the nvidia rapids team
to make sure that this is smooth so cole
can provision gpus for you
we also provided a lot of pre-configured
software environments that you can use
and modify
this ends up being actually really
critical it's challenging sometimes to
get
you know the nvidia cuda drivers to
match with the right cond environments
to match with the right
software packages and deploy those all
effectively on the right instances
coil makes that pretty easy
uh we also handle security so um
for individual users this usually isn't
so much so much of a problem
but you're still getting the same basic
best practices that
that we give to you uh my cluster over
here uh
is network secure we're running over tls
you're authenticated
uh all the information you're sending up
and down is
as well taken care of you can you can
operate in confidence
uh additionally for larger groups you
can also run coiled
inside of your own infrastructure you
can provide us
with aws credentials to manage things in
your cluster and we'll launch resources
there
uh coiled also works you know on other
other systems uh we have sort of basic
experimental support for azure right now
it's october 2020 as well as a bring
your own kubernetes approach
so coil can deploy and manage resources
on other systems
we are aws first but lots of other
systems are available
we also work on any region again we are
choosing technologies that allow us to
be
a little bit more native than a
kubernetes cluster we're running
uh anywhere that aws runs uh in
a nice way so
i'm going to sort of finish up here for
a second with some some high level
thoughts
coiled was designed to solve human and
organizational problems
in the same way that dasc was designed
to solve algorithmic or technical
problems
so coil is is free for individuals to
start
you can run everything i just ran for
free we're in beta
up to sort of 100 cores of concurrent
usage please try it out again pip
install coiled
you'll be good to go we provide
pre-configured software environments
there's lots of examples in coil that
you can run
that show lots of very cool uh dash
usage as scale
you also drive from anywhere you don't
need to pick up your development
environment
and move it to coiled coil comes to you
that's something that we really care
about in terms of ergonomics uh
we are there when you need us but we get
out of the way very quickly when you
don't
so again you can be running with coiled
on your data
on your hardware in a few minutes
we tried very hard to make that on a
ramp as easy as possible
additionally you might be trying out
cool because you're a student if so
great enjoy you might also be trying out
coiled
as a possible replacement for your you
know maybe
maybe you've gone through that same path
that we talked about you set up the
kubernetes cluster
you no longer want to be maintaining it
and so
you may be using coiled just to to try
it out to see if it's a good replacement
for what you want to do internally
and again coiled scales with you coil
runs both with individuals
and with some of the largest financial
institutions in the world and with
government groups
so we are i'm going to deploy on
infrastructure we can provide you know
manage users
teams and quotas we also track
everything that's being run and give you
a lot of sort of drill down information
on how much money did you spend parsing
csv files last quarter
a lot of the stuff ends up being really
really useful as you go to larger and
larger
organizations and again coil is built
with best practices
uh the the creators of coiled have
deployed i don't even know how many to
ask don't know how many companies so far
but we've done this lots of times we're
very good at it
and the tools that we're building make
it very easy so if you're interested in
running disc
inside of your organization a coil might
be a good fit
so i'll leave you with uh that call to
action
uh try it out you can again get a
cluster running in the next few minutes
and yeah come check us out either at
dasc.org to learn more about dasc
or coil.io to learn more about deploying
coil
that's it thank you all for your time
you